[Música]
[Aplausos]
botar de surpresa ela sofrer fita e
trabalha no ar de santa maria
portanto o segmento da terceira idade
oriental
quando comecei a surfar não existiam pra
eu posso ter minha praia eram 18 dentro
de água quando estávamos todos
este foi há 40 anos na costa da caparica
fez em outubro passado portanto mês
passado 29 anos que estou aqui em boa
terra deserta e faz hora na altura se
vai se lembrou a única punição que
chegava à praia era o crude eo alcatrão
ficamos com os pés todos tempestades é
que eu era uma chatice passei me
escutais a troca em belém pa
este alcatrão é vinha dar à costa devido
à lavagem dos tanques dos petroleiros e
era trazido pelo vento e pelas
ondulações
o que é que se passa atualmente aumenta
também a poluição que existe na praia
são os plásticos e nós possamos de 8 ser
vistas para centenas de deus
a praia está cheia plásticos e o que tem
uma imagem do da maior mancha de
plástico que existe no oceano a vários
em vários oceanos mas a maior encontra
no oceano pacífico em situa se entre a
califórnia eo avai sistemas que tem 80
mil toneladas de plástico em sua
dimensão corresponde a três vezes a área
frança nós quisermos comparar com o
nosso país são 17 vezes a área de
portugal portanto uma mancha enorme de
plástico
a existem já localidade cheio de terra
que estão fechadas ao turismo causadas
por causa do crescimento do plástico e
estragos causados processo de de turismo
é por vezes lembra da deam e problema é
que fique aqui tão próxima
eu quero que acontecerá se houver chefe
de turismo um descaso e miami vai que é
uma praia que é praia mais famosa da
tailândia e que fechou em junho deste
ano e vai taxar durante um ano para ver
se os corais recuperam em sebha ia eh eh
eh um limpa do da poluição causada por
turismo
agora vai responder a dez anos
cansada de ver tanto plástico na praia
eu adoro a praia era o mar
resolvi começar a apanhar plástico
eu vou provar isso e é isso que eu faço
todos os dias no meu caminho de volta
para a ser fada ou quando vai sair tanto
na praia também já consegue fazer na
acirrada
assim é forma que eu tenho de cuidar do
meu senhor vê a praia e agora o meu
jardim também já está nesse dado em um
espaço que eu conheço o caio
todos temos idéias positivas que podem
tornar a vida todos melhor no dia a dia
paramos com as situações em que podemos
atuar e ajudar por exemplo e acho que é
um exemplo já que quase toda a gente
ajudou alguém é carregar os sacos nas
compras ou mudar a vida do gás em casa
ou sem encontrar um animal que está
precisando de ajuda
podemos ser nós próprios ajudaram no
final da sessão cal ou ligar por cento
que é um departamento da gnr que ajuda e
que vai recolher os animais emprego mas
muitas vezes estas ideias programa
positivas e úteis por uma questão de
vergonha ou do medo da crítica dos
outros porque não compreender que o que
nós estamos a fazer e acabamos por não
não não escutaram as agências de amor
uma das instituições que acontece muito
dentro da água etá em taxas de pessoal e
nós temos regras que funcionam como as
regras de trânsito
se essas regras servem porque nós não
existam colisões e porque as pessoas não
se chegou a inventar água
nós como ser feitas mais experientes
devíamos chegaram pedro tentar fazer a
confusão quem está a deslocar-se uma
forma incorreta informar essa pessoa de
contas funciona é dentro de água todos
os dias
comparamos com certeza com as situações
que criticamos e que achamos tão mal mas
não fazemos nada achamos os braços ou
não atuarmos estamos a concordar com a
situação estamos a pactuar com a
situação e eto'o a visitava
quem cala consente
à medida que as comunidades crescem os
laços entre as pessoas têm tendência a
se separar
tantas pessoas não já não como é
cantante não tem de ser assim
um exemplo prático que acontece também
acontece aqui em peniche em vários
sítios são as hortas clínica
comunitárias em que as pessoas partilham
o espaço trocam produtos e um pm que
estava vago na passa a ser um pequeno
hotel e é assim que funciona
eu sei que já existem muitas associações
de defesa animal do ambiente etc
mas nós como indivíduos também podemos
ser ser atuante e melhoradores do espaço
que freqüentamos por exemplo vamos na
rua há um carro dava ter água podemos
comunicar com a câmara municipal e
avisar naquela rua e tal sentiu tá e aos
podem arranjar uma pedra que se encontra
a meio caminho temos que puxar para o
lado tanto a pequenas coisas que nós no
dia d
podemos fazer para melhorar o espaço que
evitamos hora porque é porque estas
pequenas há boas ações são muito
importantes que serã nós cuidarmos do
nosso dever que os pacíficos paz em que
vivemos temos que pensar que todos os
espaços públicos são financiados com
nosso trabalho então todos os passos
políticos também de potência e nós
ficávamos lá e cuidar daquilo que nós
sozinha a 10 anos observa que a quarta
praia e eu constato que há muito mais
pessoas que fazem mesmo através do nosso
exemplo prático
podemos alterar e melhorar aquilo que
nós achamos que está mal e contribuir
assim
para um ganhar todos os jogos obrigado a
fan page
[Aplausos]
[Música]